all right New York prosecutors dropped
charges against a mother arrested during
a confrontation with police that caused
a nationwide backlash video showed
officers violently pulling Jasmine
Headley's toddler from her arms Friday
at a Brooklyn social services office the
23 year old was released from jail
yesterday
Jericka Duncan shows us why Hadley's
legal trouble is not over drink good
morning good morning Headley is expected
to make a court appearance today in
Mercer County New Jersey on an arrest
warrant involving a credit card fraud
case Headley returned home late last
night she was reunited with her Sunday
Mon and her mother who was watching him
during the whole ordeal the Brooklyn
Public Defenders Office led the push to
have the charges against her in New York
dismissed and secured her release from
jail
I'm just so grateful to everyone and I'm
just happy to be free and I just need to
see my boy Headley was arrested on
Friday after a dispute with the guard
about sitting on the floor in a crowded
social services office the guard called
911 phone video showed officers yanking
Headley's 18 month old son right from
her arms the child was placed in the
custody of Headley's mother police are
reviewing the confrontation in the
Brooklyn Public Defenders Office has
asked Mercer County prosecutors to
dismiss the fraud charges saying Headley
has already been through so much and
clearly that video is disturbing even
the Brooklyn district attorney said that
he was horrified yeah my watching it
said regardless of what she had done and
there still I know two sides to every
story there had to be another way to do
it when you look in the paper this
morning in New York there's a shot of
her grabbing her baby's t-shirt with her
teeth trying to hold on to her child and
it's an instinct I mean exactly you all
know you have kids yeah he's doing that
despite whether you were wrong or right
and the Brooklyn da said it could have
been handled differently I wonder if
there will be consequences for the
officers involved in that they clearly
need retraining or I'm not sure that's
the right job for them it's very very
difficult to watch thank you drinkin
thank you